You must be confused to suddenly come to a place like this, but
who are you? What have you done to us?
What a generous budget for you, Mr. Lloyd. I
understand your confusion, but please don't worry about
me now.  I want you to listen to my words.I'm
Lloyd Bluegust
[Music] I'm
Wringle Ivy, and I'm directly in charge of that senior.You're the
hero who was summoned to our Riggle Kingdom.Please
be a hero.Don't make your image any worse.2
years agoThis world  The
demon kings of the demon tribe who were
attacked by the
demon king of  Since then, the power has
continued to grow, and I don't know what will happen next.Therefore,
as a last resort, I summoned a
Kinki magic hero who summoned someone from another world who could fight against the Demon King.Summon
DET